yaez serviceleute und herzlich
willkommen aus lünen
wir sind hier in den dünen deutschen
dünne harschen töne international bühne
wir sind an der nordsee im urlaub wir
sind heute hoch gefahren bin um halb
vier aufgestanden und fünf stunden mit
dem auto an die nordseeküste gefahren
dann heute auf der insel zu sein und
jetzt hinter hier an orte wo ist die see
eigentlich der falsche versprechen oder
mir wurde gesagt dass er die nordsee
obwohl ich werde sie noch den nordsee da
fühle ich mich auf dem boden sitzt oder
da drüben
manchmal kann sich im brunnenweg hier
legal illegal aber ist egal was ist ihre
letzten spiele sind so ein verdächtiger
schiff drin alles klar
das video ist wieder gestört und
migranten aber ich habe eine spannende
geschichte zu erzählen und zwar war ich
vor einigen tagen in berlin
das war am 27 28 juli weichen bett okay
ich bin ich hoch gefallen
ich bin ein bisschen gestört mit meinem
auto fahren also 720 nicht hochgefahren
um 8.20 wieder zurück jetzt geht euch
diese geschichte aber 28 mega viel zu
tun da hatten wir einen termin mit
google einen termin beim netzwerk damit
adrian de maistre ja noch gechillt und
das ende von der geschichte war dass ich
sehr sehr sehr spät losgefahren bin und
die fahrt von berlin dahin wo meine
familie wohnten heute ist es so unbequem
wie ich hier gerade filme und ich war
schon angezogen wie schon sexy
sie ist die tics vorausgesagt alter
schwede ist wichtig zu sagen dass die
fahrt von berlin an den ort wo ich
normalerweise wohne fünf stunden
ungefähr seines in ungefähr fünf stunden
und wer mich kennt bis auf snapshot
entweder verfolgt übrigen snapshot sg
snapped twitter ist eine beschreibung
check dass wenn ihr sehen wollt wie ich
mein leben des king auf der autobahn der
weiß dass ich sehr gern nachts war und
am ende der ganzen geschichte bin ich
einfach in berlin nachts um elf los
gefallen da zum 11 heißt bei fünf
stunden fahrt dass ich morgens um vier
ankomme so passt alles klar
ich bin die strecke gefahren ich lief
mehr oder weniger schädlich nachts schön
autobahn frei alles kein ding dann
kommen wir aber in die nähe von dem ort
wo meine familie max und wo ich mich zu
dem zeitpunkt aufgehalten habe wo ich
hin fahren wollte und ich dachte mir so
ja komm ich bin ein bisschen selbst
texte die auf machen wenn ihr findet
dass die aufpasser sexy ist dann
schreibe es in die kommentare
wir sind aber in den fucking dünn aber
leute höre ich die geschichten ich fahre
nach hause ist es so drei uhr nachts der
tank wird langsam leer von dem auto ja
ich bin immer noch rund ein kilometer
vom ort entfernt wo ich hinwollte
aber der tank mit langsam leer und ich
denk mir halt weil ich dumm war weil ja
die ganze nächte vor so wenig geschlafen
hab dachte ich mir einfach so ok kommen
jetzt kennen wir es einfach riskieren
wir es mir vor allem punk bisschen leer
getankt wird immer leerer was ich aber
nicht bedacht habe war dass es nachts um
vier bar und ich weiß nicht ob wir schon
mal eine tankstelle war aber nachts um
vier haben normalerweise nicht so viele
tankstellen auf ich fahre weiter ich
fahre weiter
und auf einmal ist der tank auf reserve
ja als beim auto gibt so eine warnung
wenn die tage auf reserve geht dann
sagte piep piep piep bittet punkte
besser sei nicht umfahren nicht weiter
aber ich will natürlich weiter gefallen
so ich höre ich meine musik ich denke
eigentlich über nicht wirklich
nachweisen spät wird schon müde und so
weiter und so fort auf einmal ist der
tank so zu 99 prozent leer und ich denke
mir so ach du scheiße wie komme ich
jetzt noch nach hause ich war immer noch
60 kilometer vom ziel entfernt ich werde
niemals mit dem tank dahin gekommen
mir so scheiße was mache ich jetzt also
gibt's davor die ganzheitlich geprägt
dann auf einmal realisiere ich so dass
ich gerade ziemlich verpackte weil leute
es war nacht und 418 fehlt keine
tankstelle auf und auf dieser autobahn
da gibt's auch einfach keine tankstellen
so ich habe darauf spekuliert dass
irgendwie tankstellen sein und bin halt
immer weiter lang gefahren foto 20
kilometer 30 km 40 kilometern ist
einfach gar nichts da es kommen keine
tankstellen dann so langsam werde ich
panisch der tank wird immer leerer immer
lehrer oder mac i scheiße du hast
verkackt du musst jetzt irgendwas machen
ich war von der autobahn ab ist doch
wirklich etwa 45 mittlerweile das soll
den rand raus in irgend so ein ganz
komisches industriegebiet also wirklich
komisch nachts um halb fünf sind viele
leute komisch aber dieses
industriegebiet war besonders komisch
bei rohstoffen handys mit google
tankstellen finden weil ich wusste nie
was machen sollte gefrorene tankstelle
google tankstellen finde gesagt mir so
als ein kilometer entfernt alles klar
was war ich gebe es war wie ein vater
hin tag ständig geschossen
dank an den tankstellen wieder in dieser
stelle der mich nachts um halb fünf der
gestank stadt fahren lassen
das habe ich dann gemacht habt ihr erst
mal okay scheiße was machst du jetzt
lässt sie jetzt in adac kommen es ist
einfach so dumm
es ist einfach so dumme sache aber so
lange autofahrt als der tank leer wird
dann war ich danach zu diesem
industriegebiet und wusste einfach nicht
was ich machen sollte der tankstellen
finder hatte versagt meine eigene
intuition hatte versagt mir gesagt dass
ich bestimmte tankstelle findet und ich
hatte einfach nur noch 0 5 prozent vom
ganzen tank so ungefähr was habe ich
dann gemacht dass mir so scheiße wisst
ihr was fakt ich riskiere jetzt einfach
bin wieder auf die autobahn gefahren und
bin weiter gefallen aber nicht irgendwie
also normal ich war nicht zu schnell 130
bis 140 km h aber zu dem zeitpunkt
hatten wir so egal du musst so weit wie
möglich kommen es geht es nur ums
überleben dann bin ich einfach 80
gefahren und ich wurde von fucking lkws
überholt links und rechts also ich weiß
die wende als autofahrer von lkws
überholt werden dann ist das der
zeitpunkt wo ihr überdenken sollten wir
autofahrer also wir haben wirklich lkws
überholte mich an leute angehupt als war
so aber ich hab gestern das geht nur
fünf minuten zehn minuten 15 minuten ich
werde auf einmal richtig nervös obwohl
so spät war wurde ich richtig nervös
machen
was passt was wenn du jetzt auf der
autobahn liegen bleibt die autobahn hat
die rechts und standstreifen teilweise
aber auch nicht wenn er ausfällt ist es
da keinen standstreifen stand was ist
wenn ich jetzt an so eine ausfahrt
stehen weil es keinen standstreifen da
muss ich auf der fahrbahn stehen
ja und dann fahren die leute vielleicht
noch in mich rein also kein scheiß das
waren auf einmal nicht mehr nur so geben
ich habe eine dummheit gemacht war
wirklich so ok fakt das könnte wirklich
bedeuten dass ich jetzt ernsthaft über
den unfall bei oder so was mich selbst
in gefahr bringen
der einzige dann gesichert hatte war
okay ganz ehrlich in der pampa da waren
keine großen städte in der nähe der
einzige was du machen kannst ist muss
geradeaus fahren zweiter fahrer
versuchen so weit wie möglich zu kommen
ich weiß nicht ob wir das nachvollziehen
können aber ich war in dem moment
wirklich richtig wichtig gestresst ich
war richtig nervös weil ich darf mir so
nachts um halb fünf da kommt niemand wer
soll die nachts um halb fünf an der
autobahn irgendwie sprit vorbeibringen
das ist da gibt's einfach niemanden da
das macht und die tankwarte gegner
weiter runter geht immer weiter runter
so bis auf null also die tanknadel war
auf null
das auto rollt noch weiter ich war so 80
halbe sie jetzt bergauf gehen 70 um
möglichst wenig zu verbrauchen nicht für
alle live streams und dann auf einmal am
horizont das schild auf dem autodach 15
20 kilometer ermöglichen fast auf null
watt kommt das schild autohof ich dachte
mir so 'oh mein gott will mit dem
letzten schritt noch raus gefahren auf
die ausfahrt dann irgendwie zu diesem
autohofs irgendwie noch geschafft diesen
autohof drauf zu fahren ich hoffe wir
können das nachvollziehen so eine ultra
kasse presseplätze für mich obwohl ich
so müde war
liebe recht müde davor oder auf einmal
zack wieder hellwach hatte der düster
verkackt ich habe mich selbst geärgert
und ich weiß nicht auf die ausfahrt raus
und zum auto muss man nur noch links
abbiegen ich war schon weg von der auto
war ich habe mir so ganz ehrlich ist es
wahrscheinlich dass mein auto ist an
dieser ampel stehen bleibt und nicht nur
die 50 meter bis zum auto gemacht aber
am ende hat es dann geklappt ich hoffe
den autohof und tank randvoll und die
moral von der geschicht ist leute wenn
ihr autofahrt seid nicht dumm tank
lieber einmal früher als einmal zu spät
gerade wenigen nachts autofahrt riskiert
nicht dass ihr auf der autobahn liegen
bleibt ist es sei dumm und saugefährlich
und kann so teuer werden ja und in
diesem sinne ersehnten dem urlaub heute
erster tag leute das war so eine galerie
lovestory welches gefällt dass auf jeden
fall feedback in den kommentaren da
schreibt man sich vielleicht nicht so
gefallen hat
dass man leute wenn ich zwei meter